[Musik]
im tessin in einen abgelegenen
seitenteil des machata schlägt ganz
hinten die alb munter weiter nur einen
steinwurf von der italienischen grenze
entfernt
[Musik]
für ihn und markus senn aus dem kanton
zürich beginnen hier oben in den 80er
jahren als aussteiger ihren lebenstraum
umzusetzen
[Musik]
müssen die sogenannte 86 grundidee
bewegung wohl wald video um sich griff
hat mir einfach sehen dass neue jobs vor
mir wichtig sind und mehr handwerk
demonstrieren oder die gäste um den
führer bis und handeln probiert ja der
oberarzt fangen mit dem bedburger
projekt
wir haben dass ich die folge sie
tausende mit der familie beginnt und
haben könne
grund und boden kaufen und rufus beck
heimat nach us muster mit tier und natur
und in harmonie sowie deshalb kam 1986
ziehen ferien und markus n mit ihren
sechs kindern ins tessin hier auf über
1400 metern gibt es nichts außer der
natur die familie schläft in tipis
improvisation ist angesagt infrastruktur
wie die zufahrt was stromkabel und das
richtig gemacht
jedem wurde leipzig bildung schön
erwartet und diese anderen ein wohnhaus
hat priorität aber den tessiner behörden
missfallen die baupläne verzweifelt wenn
sich ferdinand marcos senna an die
medien
das schweizer fernsehen und die
zeitschrift beobachter berichten die
medien berichten reagiert und
geschrieben und so und dann ist es
eigentlich den vorwärtsgang mit mit
reese war der könig ist und die wir mit
den lütow der noris tg saar abkauft
haben und mit mit mit unterstützung
haben sie im fotos liegt hätte es
geholfen oder bauen oder so das ist
immer sehr wertvoll xing markus und
verena sein sind gezwungen aufwendiger
zu bauen als sie wollten
denn ohne minimale betriebsgröße
erhalten sie keine subventionen riesige
sache planet gehabt nein natürlich leben
bescheiden blieben so habe wo man mit
behörden kontakt kostenseite willebrand
java mobile kreatur und und war mit
villa wohnen und so haben wir draußen
schon ist ein hans krawall show dann
mindestens so groß willst du disque
existenz und das begriffen sie fällt
nicht wirklich subventionieren oder
bewillige was zum vornherein wusste das
nicht existiert oder und dann sind sie
ein stahlbogen für für 40 höher
heute steht der hof dort wo die familie
am anfang ihre tipis aufgestellt hatte
und leiter ist einer von über 300 bio
bergbau betrieben die sich in der
gesellschaft berg heimat organisiert
haben
zum hof gehört ein großer garten was sie
nicht selbst brauchen verkauft verena
seien auf dem markt in locarno
es brauchte viel mut und sie wussten
ohne knochenarbeit für der traum nicht
funktionieren
[Musik]
die knie ist dann habe ich sie und die
anderen solidarpakt ii waren können und
so alle kinder sind erwachsen und mit
einer ausnahme längst ausgezogen
zusammen mit den eltern lebt heute noch
so einsam auf dem hof mit sachs kurve
sie natürlich spannend xj und verena
markus miele werk beschäftigt sie mit
dem aufbau nicht einfach sie und zieht
so verließ natürlich sind mithelfen dass
wir das ganze nicht so groß aber ja sie
ist einfach us-botschaft sie schaffe
gemachten vorwurf standen maschinen
wichtig mal
das programm ist so und so war das kind
mag sein dass nicht ja gesagt du machst
du machst du keinen gedanken
davids mir das passt oder nicht durchaus
höchstens der vergleich vor dem
schulkollegium rief er ihr geld oder der
kirche mit dem titel tätig sind von
denke ja
hier haben wir geschafft und dann wird
es schwierig ducati hat er keine
bedenken gar nicht andere möglichkeiten
da funktioniert 81 so unterschiedlich
die gewalt
einen abhang hinter dem hof wird im
winter zur rennstrecke
[Musik]
es sind seltene momente in denen die
familie schafft den alltag beiseite zu
lassen
[Musik]
was haben
als hobbyfilmer dokumentiert markus auch
das leben neben der arbeit feriengäste
helfer und die familie stehen dann im
mittelpunkt
[Musik]
nein
barbara das jüngste der sechs kinder hat
den hof mit 16 verlassen um eine
ausbildung als tourismusfachfrau zu
starten
sie lebt heute in der stadt zürich ist
unbekannt
ja das sind so die dachwohnung es
meistens um frontmann zurückkam und
leiter bank fiel eigentlich natürlich
unter dem motto tagesstruktur ist offen
aber muss laufen viel arbeit machen und
diesen immer wieder momente geben
wirklich zu dir verbracht
einfach nie
im dorf chi x motto zwei kilometer
unterhalb der alb reden sich die letzten
verbliebenen einwohner die augen dass
die deutschschweiz abgelegenen tal
einwanderten
die heimische die hand nizza nach höchst
visuelle die ordner sind sie eigentlich
oder hantieren sind immer im vordergrund
aber nicht statt werden du bist gründen
weg vor dem herd erlangen und jetzt
runter familie mit sachsen und hund
macht geteilt der hand hier schon
gedankt ja was ich da und jan den augen
beobachtet und manchmal sind sie und man
sind weniger freundlich sie also mehr
und da ist schon irgendwie rein optisch
maxisch wenn es so schön heißt es beim
übergang wäre das sehr mühsam feinfühlig
sie dann mit mir hier sein könne
integrieren
die ja alles zusammen gebäude xi und
dementsprechend hat dann alles halt so
der grohag no und das 1
viele tun halt nicht so verstanden
morgen sind stoffe der laufer mit dem
schulbus stunden aufgabe ich einen apfel
oder noch viele dafür griffiger so
bestimmen kann so laut wird und als die
schweizer im tessin dann obhut und berge
das sind ja verhindern oder die armee
xxi
[Musik]
ja mit der rückschlag
verena die ehemalige buchhändlerin und
markus der gelernte schriftsetzer sind
im ahv-alter angekommen
seit der 68er bewegung sind sie ein paar
[Musik]
die hippies aus den usa machen es vor
der alternative lebensstil wird auch in
der schweiz zum thema neue formen des
zusammenlebens werden ausprobiert
markus und verena hinterfragen
konsumdenken und wirtschaftswachstum
und sie wollen der zunehmenden
umweltzerstörung etwas entgegensetzen
[Musik]
das ist lahms buch für das erinnern und
mehr mit dem symbol vom laves bounty
hunter silikon slawistik quelle
klinische lieben und bebildern und
bezeichnen und so sieht aber leider
nicht also vitro einige jahr haben wir
das gemacht und dann wieso ist mit allen
projekten irgendwann ist dann auf einmal
bis an das wichtige und dania blieb
sollte dann einfach stark
und jetzt schaut einfach das klappt ist
relativ dünn
auf jeden fall was wichtig ist
das ist das mio ein anderer ex vorstand
der gesellschaft eine hand jo mitwisser
sachen einfach problem kann wie damals
alle 68
da sehr strikt und haben es mal probiert
in der stadt wir sind eigentlich vom
land und dann dahinter steht aber
gemerkt dass das wieder so große sache
zu beginn der 70er jahre wohnten
ferdinand marcos in einem besetzten haus
an der venedig straße in zürich die
straße existiert heute nicht mehr
venedig straßenwesen komplexen beiden
stoffe
[Musik]
die stadt verkaufte die straße samt den
historischen gebäuden an einen privaten
investor um den abbruch der häuser
gruppe zu verhindern kam es zu
protestaktionen
markus arena demonstrierten mit mit dem
bentley cabrio dann das camp gemacht auf
1800 meter im wallis das ebenso richtig
wie offen
indianer trikot hand probiert aber der
hand so steif report und hand hier mit
transparent bespannt als dach wo man
lokal von rom wald demo hericks zürich
haben wir mitglieder gestrichen und die
steckt und jeder hat das individuellste
bauer und die haben nur
gemeinschaftsküche und der krise ganz
super league tor bugsieren kann das
öffentlich gemacht das heißt es amtlich
oberhand wähler interessant ich bin da
aufgewachsen dritte tochter also immer
überhaupt kein vorbild ich kann das paar
kürzlich oscar und der anfang nach
rüthen sammler und nachher ja eigentlich
nur als hobby hat eigentlich dass ich
dat eent stoff kommt aber nach es in
haltern muss mensch hat die zahl problem
gesundheitliche und dann hat man halt
ausprobiert
[Musik]
eines tages kommt plötzlich polizei über
sich getrost war das ganz ohne nach hat
hansa sie zog in hand laufen einzelne
machen und nachhaltig sein
ich kann das macht pro tag
so war der letzte wechsel im team ganz
erstaunlich jetzt toll und verschließe
mich kommen und dann ist fertig sie in
hand zusammen packen sie kommen aber am
bass mich schon sehr interessant die lab
auf die xxi aber man hat dann schon so
dass man eigentlich schon noch nicht so
gemeinschafts fähig sind wie mir das
sowieso sofort stellt an will ja alle
aus einer familie loosli situationen
hoher sicherheit christ wir dass man
gemeinschaftlich soll funktionieren also
vorsatz in die idee als sie aber ebenso
wie ich mit den ideal umsetzungsstand
auch noch besonders vor allem aus
überhaupt also nicht erst fassen oder
vision war ja schon wäre schon großartig
sie
es ist schon eine art das move ist in
der flucht das gibt zu also wir haben es
einfach nicht so vertraut sagt sind in
der gesellschaft wenn die hand dies
bringe
juni die unterschiedlichsten mit zweig
sind dann da einfach mit welle die die
schwierigkeit in kauf
wir halten also ich habe jetzt nicht so
dank die verdankt ich wieder sind nur
wisse die nahrungsmittel herkommen und
was man die für natur und feeling mit
der natur leben
das ist das ist schon priorität das ist
dadurch wird der beton steht trostlos
ich und du also eher symbolisch für kind
und wieder extra also da muss schon früh
um haben dass hans natürlich ein schock
aus es hat immer zwei zimmer über das
schoko und das was sich gesellschaftlich
sozial wenig und hans dafür auf die
andere seite kompensieren mit ein
erlebnis und sie sind und wirklich ihr
könnt uns
ich konnte viele fähigkeiten der ganze
hof und hotel gelebt
mit eben eine positive und weniger
positive momente ich bin die sache und
ich haben von prozent verdoppeln und
fragte wem geben meistens einfach hätte
ich habe halt
als einziges 610 kinder hat sami eine
landwirtschaftliche ausbildung
abgeschlossen und kommt damit am ehesten
als nachfolger auf dem hof in frage
sammer hatte lust in zukunft auch berg
honig zu produzieren
anfangs juli haben die entwickelt und
jetzt haben wir da prototypen nach
erster bürger wie sich das bewährt
das weiß ich gar nicht ob snow mal sind
es ja hallo gab es nix mine la colorada
[Musik]
im internet www gesine und die anderen
sagen dass berg leben ist hart
alles andere als idyllisch wie es tag
für tag lebt kennt auch die
schattenseiten und das im bunde sie mit
jeder tag schaffe noch etliche wochen
training gegentreffer des menschens
stunde befahren
ein weiter so
da wir damit ja ich habe mich los da
sich also
[Musik]
fürs lesen ist für ihn verantwortlich
seit 30 jahren verarbeitet sie jeden
morgen 150 liter milch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen teil des altkreises verschickt
verena per post an eine treue kundschaft
in der ganzen schweiz bald werden die
sens die produktion aufgeben müssen
die arbeit ist zu streng und zu
aufwendig
ein freies selbstbestimmtes leben haben
sie gesucht und teilweise auch gefunden
aber markus kämpft immer häufiger mit
depressionen
nächtelang als karussell kann es nämlich
einen abstellen
einfach nur das hat immer die gleiche
gedanke sind einfach tur tur tur tur
obwohl ich schon lange welle schlafen
aber ich sind schon gegangen
was als schwierig sich halt
gesundheitszustand von markus söder der
hat natürlich sehr prägt weil das meint
natürlich immer du singen depression und
sowie dem zehnten rang ab
natürlich müsse sich dementsprechend
verhalten und so sind natürlich
aufgewachsen also mit geräten die die
wellen astern und sie brauchen und dann
fragten sich was kann man machen aber
irgendwann als neuem sound raffungen
auges im aufbau für den reiter ist das
gar nie dazu rote heftige kritik
ich bin der woche trainiert ich glaube
sie sind mit duftreis kita mal so viel
man könne das denkt sich dass die geduld
und dennis ihn sind und durch schafe ist
das eben nachhinein das ruder hinterland
bereiten und benehmen vor allem das
nicht nachvollziehbar
[Musik]
markus und fernsehen haben sorgen um die
zukunft für den hof zu sichern muss die
nachfolge geregelt sein muss so
akzeptieren und fraglich kurz gefühlen
zurück ruhige und jetzt gut zu
[Musik]
sami möchte den betrieb umstellen von
milchkuhhaltung auf mutterkuhhaltung
dies bedeutet die kälber bleiben nach
der geburt bei der mutter die
milchproduktion fällt weg als ein taxi
das sie trainiert also ich kann ja nicht
alles allein machen das ganz leicht
nichts jetzt alles drum und ratschläge
zur miete
bescheiden in vollziehung der messe
haben dass ein paar wiener kinos zahlen
da ich im hinterhof im hintergrund
existiert hat gar nicht mehr dann hier
wirklich groß gedanken gemacht
selbständig oder eigene existenz
unabhängig vom aufbau und jetzt langsam
pensioniert sind wurde ist nehmen
konkreter wollte eigentlich könnten
ferien und markus stolz sein auf das was
sie geschaffen haben
aber sami schülern den hof zu übernehmen
bedrückt chemischer klar dass er das
nummer der familie gemacht aber er macht
sitzt und so uns definitiv ist das
eigentlich
hundertprozentige bezüglich machen muss
könne gott und die hat die freiheit und
das gesagte mio das wirkt alles wie
geplant
ja es ist sie mir die standspur das mich
dann einfach wieder wie sie zuvor mich
dass mich einfach wieder die richtigen
töne das ganze kabine und das ist
einfach noch nicht so weit ist das noch
nicht
und dann mache ich hatte mich hat das
ich hatte aus dem feld haben wir seit
jahren 1000 1000 thorsten zu machen
sami ist 42 und wünscht sich eine eigene
familie eine partnerin zu finden die
hier oben leben möchte ist schwierig es
ist ganz energien hof ihr stecke oder
bistros machen und nachher schluss ang
lee kompliment
sag ja soll ist dann das ganze mache
überhaupt oder bliebe dann allein und
mach es oder gar nicht an
sport ist natürlich dann war der hang
ist an gemacht alles also ist es auf
rang 8 klettern könnte
[Musik]
die ungelöste hofnachfolge und der
alltags druck werden zu viel
ausgerechnet an seinem geburtstag recht
markus zusammen
die ambulanz bringt ihn ins spital
das ist noch schwierig dass man aus berg
tut muss zurück dass man auch an in
bernau dinner for speed oder andere
manager und stress die leute aus der
wirtschaft in berlin sicher rolle zum
beispiel von burnout zu wechseln und
sich dann einfach die miri gestalters
wann ein alternativ ist auch freude
macht und man sich dann dermaßen mit
identifizierten time out trip und es gut
machen und noch besser machen dass man
genau die gleiche situation in der hand
ihn im management wir haben tagelang
nächtelang vor allem in der nacht so
genanntes karussell k ich bin ich auf
die idee so dass das 1 2 per handy
strecke herum liegt ihm auch gelingt
aber nur sechs ist auch so ein messgerät
mit der weichen oder aber es ist halt
einfach doch einmal zehn wurde der
körper psyche alle sich überfordert sind
und wo das passiert ist eigentlich
wirklich
dass der müll gibt
sito weiß ich was das bedeutet wenn
manche sich warum bringen wo sie zwei
fliegen panik und angst aus
verschiedensten sachen und da bin ich
liegt saisonsieg und zwar nicht mit
unterstützung von ihm eine frau ist
das ist vorüber die menschliche
schriftzugs haben
[Musik]
bei freunden im zürcher weinland tankt
markus kraft für die rückkehr
[Musik]
verena die kinder und freunde halten
unterdessen auf munter weiter die
stellung
[Musik]
ich mache ja so habe das überstanden und
ich habe ja spiele ausgerichtet so
schwer es gab schon gegangen ist also
wenn irgendwo stadt wie gut sie zwitter
und da muss probieren
du hast ihn eigentlich alles gut
ausschaut regeneration scripts
handschrift dass das wirklich gut gott
und das deb trikot
das heißt nicht dass wir nicht alles
könne ihnen mobilisieren und also
probiert wichtig und er hat es geschafft
dann hat sich vieles zum guten gewandelt
und ich danke ihnen auch hinein es ist
nicht die sache haben wir alle
historische alles für geistiges niedrig
lewis ist ein weg sie wo intensiv und
hab ich sie ist aber wenn es nötig ist
so passiert weiß ich und das haben sie
dann auf jede persönlich auf dem weg
eine entschuldigung für mich ist ganz
wichtig sind ich bin jetzt eigentlich
gut
trainer markus keller und wie ist immer
die stadt sich also mit dem trainermarkt
dann haben wir dann drüber leitet sich
gar nicht wohl und das ist das habe ich
ihnen immer ganz fair news
[Musik]
die hand also steckt sie locker dass wir
nicht wissen was sie erreichen den fokus
immer noch im zielraum
aber mir dass man das ziel erreichen
entlasten also verglichen mit dem
bergbau nur im verlauf gekämpft und war
doppelt zählt nur wieder aber nein das
ist unsinn sie forderte dagegen der
lösungen und lag zu ende
[Musik]
zwar noch das dach hier kann nach
längerer auszeit des markus endlich
zurück im tessin und will wieder tritt
fassen
einfach ist das nicht die schweren
gedanken sind immer noch da tele2 meines
therme vor allem die tosca und wollen
wir direkt sagen der nummer quotient und
schlussendlich hat es dann doch klappt
sind wir alle sehr froh und entlastet
noch einmal der hof übernommen und das
scheppern jetzt mit sammy davis ich es
entwickelt und was sich dagegen trotz
oder klappt es nicht weiß es noch nicht
da wusste ich natürlich verantworten hat
dafür das risiko für die hopstener
caruso über die behälter und bank und
alles und nichts mehr verloren das sie
dass sie da sind ja nicht recht ist
zilina haben wir mein vater damals im
westen gelang
gleich ausgeschlossen war ich kurz hat
mir das einmal aber ich muss immer
wieder weg wenn es brenzlig wird
burnout und yoko ich sagen es ist so
wenn das monster hinter mir postenführer
lockt ein beobachtet und womöglich mit
trainer oder darüber tut sich gefordert
sich wieder schluss zu dass uns so
sprechen ist doch angst vor der gewalt
geht schon trick und doch auf die
intuition lose meint intuition zeit
du machst du was er zum beispiel macht
yoga oder machte langlauf oder machte
marathon
ich mache die romane und dann ist
solange das von bordeaux im für sie fürs
gemüt energisch deal auf der rückfahrt
ins penalty nach möglichkeiten hat im
werkzentrum wäre bevor die gemeinschaft
da sehe ich mich angesetzt
wir wollen einen immer musste ich bin
nun stoppt und dann muss das haben
man muss selbst im krieg hat nur gemälde
entstand eine sekunde und wird mit mir
so schlecht traurig das ist natürlich
gossips zustand soll das ist einfach das
leben möglichst vermieden
ein halbes jahr später mit den neuen
mutterkühen geht es zum ersten mal auf
die alm der neue chef denkt über die
zukunft nach dem user finden wie pelé
der das café das machen mit makro
tourismus mahlbetrieb und jahresthema
kulturprojekt vorstand kommt ja und sind
dafür steht eine berufsgruppe oder
seminare machen aber jetzt alles mal die
tore nicht machen
tanja back up gemacht wird zum der
stadtumbau garage umbau des hörsaal
energetisch sanieren
bei real zum gar nichts
[Musik]
ich rede ja kommt dazwischen ich
vielleicht beste schauen das darlehen
eines italien bisher größte gerade
glücklich sterben habe
bisher bringt war sondern reinhardt denn
auf die richtige partnerin warteten noch
immer seien dalí meistens dass ich mein
altes lager schritt weg von frauen immer
noch mit älteren muss man sich sowieso
nicht einfach hier bei mir gesagt du
bist aber munter weiter für viel rate
markus findet nun endlich zeit für ein
projekt von dem er schon seit jahren
träumt jetzt kann er es umsetzen sowie
funktionieren
hier entsteht ein permakultur garten
permakultur orientiert sich an den
kreisläufen der naturen gute ernte
erträge mit weniger aufwand ist das ziel
die ganze vorbereitet
damit wir danach ihren terrassen machen
für obst und ja ich glaube ja ja ich
glaube und zündete zwischen dinge gut
machen es gut dass man das heute bringen
wir das mal eben nicht sich überfordert
aber sie richtig gestalten sind nämlich
noch einmal begründen aber also wirklich
dann werde ich auch nie die media
sondern nur mai juni juli bis fertig
politisch und nach einer kita short
[Musik]
hat das nur schnell kann so ziemlich
alle aber sicherlich für darf dass sie
immer geschafft sind und dass die immer
wieder energie findet um 11 uhr ist ja
dass ich das macht jetzt so wie ich das
genauso normal wie machen das könnte ich
jetzt nicht einfach ja sage ich danke
meiner kinder dank wenn du als familie
groß ist auch die haptik sie also
pioniere müssen schon gut überlegte wie
rogers händler wie weit weg vor allem
und nach hat der schulweg und ja so
schwierig sind und dass man dann einfach
nicht wenig zählt hat für den namen der
familie von dem her würde extrem ja aber
nicht so jung und busch privat bin ich
sie befehligt aber völlig download aber
zum glück weiß million etwas ein brutal
dass man darauf achten dass viele stock
in der bibel naja aber es ist jetzt
menschen und gott vita und das ist die
hauptsache
[Musik]